[Applaudissements]
une rapidité devant vous un ramequin de
moutarde avec une cuillère il a levé un
mot et il y en a beaucoup en ville et
vous pouvez pas tricher 3 2 1 on y va il
faut le finir ses matches et capucine
ouais rien qu'à ce jour très bien de
donner encore et là c'est délicieux ça
aurait très bien sur la gold à une
technologie c'est capucine qui a perdu
alors
[Applaudissements]
vous devez boire vous devez pas vraiment
où le monsieur ne jamais de la vie
mais ça me regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
oh
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible ça ne tient pas
debout
[Applaudissements]
n'empêche il a la bosse il faut bien
expliquer parce qu'à pu sirem s'acheter
des nouvelles sans nouvelle je l aimais
poupon l'autre est bien là vraiment il
alla la résistance